apple finally revealed their iphone 13
lineup but they conveniently left out
many things about the regular iphone 13
and the 13 pro both good things and not
so good now some of these will affect
which iphone model you should buy along
with storage options and accessories you
should go with so make sure to pay
attention as we go through everything we
found about these new phones let's start
with some simple ones the first is a
bummer to me personally and that's the
fact that all of the new iphones are
thicker and heavier this year now the
mini is only five percent heavier and it
was already lightweight so it doesn't
matter that much the regular 13 is six
percent heavier or 10 grams still not
too bad but the iphone 13 pro which was
already heavy now weighs 204 grams or
the same exact as the note 20 ultra
which is much larger with a huge battery
and an s-pen the 13 pro max which was
already a big boy now weighs 240 grams
that's starting to get close to a galaxy
full 3 or an ipad mini 6 and that is
thanks to a thicker stainless steel
frame with bigger batteries and camera
bumps speaking of those bumps apple kept
showing off renders of them but what
they didn't actually mention is that
they are massive and so much larger and
thicker than the iphone 13 camera bumps
which themselves are bigger than the
iphone 12 models these things stick out
so much the apple is now putting rings
on the outside of their cases to protect
the huge lenses so if you're somebody
who hates big bumps or when your phone
rocks back and forth on your desk keep
that in mind on the flip side we have
the notch which for the first time since
its release in the iphone 10 has been
changed apple said it's now 20 smaller
thanks to a reduction in width but what
they conveniently left out is that it is
actually taller than it was before i
knew that something looked off when i
saw it and it reminded me of the hideous
pixel 3xl unibrow but now i know why
let's mention a few positives before we
get into more negatives if you're
somebody that paid an arm and a leg to
replace broken or cracked back glass
apple care can now be used to replace
cracked back glass for only 29
instead of the previous 100 or a massive
599 on the iphone 12 pro max or the 13
for max if you don't have apple care so
make sure to buy that if you're not
going to use the case with that these
new iphones now support dual e sims so
if you'd like you can finally skip using
a sim card at all but don't expect three
separate sims to work along with that it
seems like apple is completely stopping
shipping his iphones with sim cards
altogether along with that even though
apple didn't mention it it does seem
like they are using brand new 5g modems
on these new iphones for two reason the
first being that the whole 13 lineup has
additional bands which also means that
the 13 and the 13 mini have the same
exact data speeds and connectivity as
the pro models but with that we're also
seeing an improvement in battery life
for streaming video which likely means
that this new modem is a 5 nanometer one
like the snapdragon x60 or possibly a
different one instead of the power
hungry x 55 and the iphone 12s but more
on battery life in just a bit and now on
to something that i was extremely
excited about but after digging into
some fine print i am definitely way more
skeptical not as optimistic and that is
the brand new cinematic video mode this
is an absolute breakthrough in video
tech that destroys what samsung has been
doing for years now instead of baking in
this unnatural blur that ruins your
video if it goes off a bit you can
actually apply and adjust the effect in
post you can also select if you wanted
to focus on faces and rack focus
automatically or select the people that
you want to be the main focus and even
change focus between objects you can
also adjust how much blur it adds so it
doesn't look too fake or completely
remove it if the scene doesn't work out
there is nothing out there that matches
this level of control other than a real
camera so it is no wonder that apple
spent so much time on it but there is
just one catch that they didn't mention
and that is the fact that it only works
when shooting 1080p video and only at 30
frames per second now i know why so much
of the video looked soft when they
showed it off and i can't understand why
it's limited to 1080p there's just so
much data that needs to be processed and
of course they do want to upsell you on
the iphone 14 pro which will probably be
able to do it in 4k but it is still a
bummer to go back to 1080p video after
shooting 4k since the iphone 6s yes that
was a while ago apple also confirmed the
long rumored prores recording making the
iphone a more pro video device they
cleverly mentioned that the 13 pro can
shoot pro res meaning the regular 13
can't which is acceptable but they also
snuck in that the 13 pro can shoot
cinematic video or pro res meaning not
both so you either get the cool blur or
less compression artifacts and there is
one more catch if you buy a 128 gig
iphone 13 pro like i always do since i
use icloud they are also limiting that
prores recording to 1080p just like the
cinematic mode man i guess 2021 is the
year of 1080p
if you want to shoot pro res in 4k you
better cough up some extra cash for at
least 256 gigabytes of storage so yes
this is a software limitation just to
save you on storage space now on the
positive side this year thankfully there
are no camera differences between the 13
pro and the 13 pro max like we had last
year so if you like the smaller size or
you want to save 100 bucks and put that
towards extra storage you are not going
to lose out like you did with the iphone
12 pro and with that we will likely have
the biggest camera quality differences
we have ever seen between the regular
and the pro models just take another
look at the size difference of the
camera bumps even though the 13 is
inheriting the iphone 12 pro max's
camera system with the sensor
stabilization and the photos will be
good the pro models are getting massive
updates and they're going to be a lot
better they have new three-time zoom
lenses with night mode capabilities the
much upgraded ultrawide camera that not
only captures a lot more light but can
now take insane macro shots which is not
possible with the iphone 13 or the 13
mini and even though apple finally gave
4k 60 hdr video capture support to the
13 which was just a software limitation
before we still don't have night mode
portrait support which makes a massive
difference in these kinds of low light
shots if you guys want to see an ultra
detailed camera comparison between the
iphone 13 and the 13 pro hit that
subscribe button below and with that you
guys can help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers we would definitely
appreciate it now as you may have seen
the iphone 13 gained two and a half
hours of battery life compared to the
iphone 12 whereas the 13 pro only gained
one and a half hours now that is because
of the new pro motion display that could
take more power but what apple didn't
specifically mention is that it can also
use less power as well if we look at the
detailed battery life specs you'll see
that when watching video the 13 pro
actually gets three extra hours of video
playback from the device itself or up to
five extra hours when streaming compared
to the iphone 13. now i'm not sure why
there's a bigger difference when
streaming than from local storage maybe
because of the extra graphics being more
efficient but the better battery life is
definitely because of the new promotion
display dropping all the way down to 10
hertz instead of being locked at 60
hertz this means that when you're
watching movies or videos the display
can match 24 or 30 fps to have less
judder and to save battery and the same
thing goes for games this is basically
like g-sync so if you're playing games
at lower frame rates it will feel
smoother and you will save battery so
basically even though apple said the 13
will have better battery it really
depends on what you do so don't buy the
13 just for that and along with that
they also didn't mention the amounts of
ram these phones have the 13 pro still
has 6 gigabytes while the 13 has 4
gigabytes so unfortunately we don't have
any changes but we did get a process
change of course the a15 but apple was
very sly about that they were very vague
in performance stating things like the
fastest processors ever and better than
competition but that is because not that
much of improvement has been made on the
cpu side probably the smallest upgrade
in years only jumping from 4200 up to 4
800 in the pro max models but thankfully
on the graphics side we have really good
improvements at least with the iphone 13
pro models 5 core graphics leaked
geekbench metal scores show 14 200 which
is insane performance upgrade compared
to the iphone 12 pro max's 9000 or close
to 60 percent but if you go for the
iphone 13 that drops all the way down to
10 600 which isn't really worth
upgrading for so if you play games
definitely go for the pro model now the
last discovery is a bit of a funny one
iphones have been able to fast charge to
50 in 30 minutes for many years now but
this year apple didn't mention that this
is no longer the case if you buy the 13
pro max it will now take 35 minutes to
reach 50 percent with a 20 watt power
adapter because that is no longer enough
to charge its bigger battery now sure
the five extra minutes doesn't really
matter but what apple also didn't
mention is that the pro max models can
actually accept more than 20 watts of
charging the 12 for max accepted up to
23 watts so who knows this one might do
25 26 27 we'll test it out once we get
it so if you're buying a fast charger
for your pro max and you want the
fastest speeds pick up at least a 30
watt charger to get the fastest speed
i'll go ahead and link one down below
along with the 21 anchor for just 11
bucks as tiny and as prongs we highly
recommend that one as well so thank you
guys for watching let us know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below click that subscribe button above
to help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers we would greatly appreciate
it check out one of those great videos
over there that's been max and i will
see you in the next video
[Music]